Tối cho đề định vấn tương lai thúc đầy trên đối kinh tế hôm tới phát triển công bằng tạng diện và bình vấn.
Hội nghĩ đến nếu quốc về thương mại và phát triển,
un tát lần thứ mấy sảo dễn ra tại trên nè, thế sĩ, từ ngày 20 đến 2018,
sẽ là cô hội quan trọng đề định nghiênh lại thương mạng tần câu,
đặc biệt trong bối cạnh bất ổn giá tâm.
Tất biểu hợp báo tộc tục kiểu un tát niệm mạnh,
thương mại tại chính đối tư và không lệnh thương còn là những bọn đề dương vị đối,
mà đã cần kết truy nhiêu và hội nghiệm sất tối sẽ cùng đánh ra xem có phấn đề này
của anh vường tối những một điều phát triển bình vấn thêm không?
Chúng ta đang chương kiến hồ sự chuyển dịch măng tỷ đột phát,
trong thương mại đa thương,
như quốc định mà chúng ta đưa ra tại hội nghiệm sẽ tất lộn lệnh tương lai thương mại,
chính sách và các cuộc tranh lỗi phát triển tàn cầu.
Chào mỗi ngày diễn ra hội nghiệm, chúng ta sẽ đối mắt bối một số thích quan trọng nhất trong lệnh tiến tế tàn cầu
và đi ở tinh để hợp thời đại chúng ta.